non une arme et est toujours constitué
de la même façon on part toujours de
l'arrière on a toujours une crosse
ensuite c'est toujours une poignée
pistolet qui sert au maintien de larmes
d'accord vous êtes toujours ici à ponte
qui protège la queue de détente à
l'intérieur qu'il faut s' est le plus
réactif possible
je voyais pas mal de personnes sur des
groupes notamment de facebook qui
décidez de partir en ukraine sans aucune
expérience comme ça sur un coup de tête
je pensais que la meilleure façon fin à
leur façon à moi de contribuer à sa de
les aider c'était de leur donner un
petit vernis voilà justement ne pas
laisser partir à l aventure comme ça et
de leur apprendre vraiment la base du
combat
tiger woods a qu'à gauche
en deux jours nous serons pas d'en faire
des guerriers parce que les forêts
beaucoup plus longtemps forêt se
compteraient presque en année
je vais là-bas en connaissance de cause
en étant prêt à sacrifier ma vie en
sachant je viendrai pas forcément mais
après le problème c'est que là j'ai
l'impression que si j'avais je vais y
aller un peu court y en a que je vais
mourir dans les premiers instants et que
ça va servir à absolument rien du tout
parce que
comme on aura 2 après avoir un petit peu
réfléchi je pense que ce n'est pas
forcément une bonne idée n'est on pas
forcément d'expérience militaire sur le
terrain et je me suis peut être orienté
vers l'humanitaire donc faire une
formation comme ça ça peut toujours
servir parce que on sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver
[Musique]
s'engage pour une livre la liberté des
gens pour la démocratie pour que les
gens puissent vivre en paix courage a
pas de juste ma solidarité c'est
vraiment juste un choix personnel jeudi
roman rester comme ça dans mon canapé à
regarder cette mrc nos révoltes le jour
de l'attaqué que ce arrivé ici
lagardère fille j'ai cédé à peu le truc
le sar me coucher ça me revient dans la
tête ça cogite pendant matin ça mais
l'air las prodigieux qu'elles seront
aussi je pense a été efficace
[Musique]
et pas d'espérance spécial dans tout ce
qui est logistique ou au parc ont une
espérance du coup militaire que jules
roja dans les batailles demande dis-je
de jaca puisque à deir ezzor sur le
front du style ou bon c j'ai pris les
armes et l'eau de la baja pris les armes
légères donc c'est des compétences que
je peux mettre en avant
c'est pas un engagement de à les trois
mois quatre mois c'est pas un tour de
tous russes s'est tu viens sans
l'engagement raison que j'en ferais qui
n'arrêtent pas d'envoyer des messages
non mais si tu peux faire marche arrière
par exemple je dis merci à 6 par an je
m'engage ici c'est sur la victoire soit
rien kouassi a pas de non ça va pas ou
on se retire ou autre nom c'est un
engagement
s'est pas dit oui ce que les gens de
leur issue
[Musique]